You
So I had to run to go pee pee.
It is good. I am fine.
Yeah you hear me. Can you hear me?
I want more. I want more.
Wait, I have to do the thing here.
I have to do the thing here.
How to do the thing here. I forgot. I forgot.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait. I got this.
Yes, I am so smart.
Oh my god, I didn't add the thing here.
I forgot. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I can't believe I forgot to do that.
I do that like every night. Every night before I go to bed.
BAM! Just like, oh my arm.
My arm.
I did it.
Today was a good day.
I am okay. Let me do a little stretching.
Oh my god.
One.
Hi my little bleeding heart.
I bleed it.
Bleed, bleed, bleed, bleed.
Why is there bread on your booba?
Because I like bread.
YouTube likes bread too.
So I give you two bread.
Bread.
See?
I like bread.
Bread.
I am the most professional streamer ever.
What do you mean?
I am so professional.
I am super professional.
Why isn't the chat moving?
But I was scrolled down.
I have to scroll down.
What?
Give me a second.
How does it turn on my light?
Wait.
No.
Alright.
I am fine.
Are you?
Hey.
I am doing okay.
I was celebrating my
being off a bunch of medications,
healing, celebrating.
It was the first time I had a drink in a long time.
It's been almost a year.
Almost a year since I had a drink in the drink.
Drink it.
I had a drink.
The last time I had a drink.
Yeah.
Drink it.
I started drunk.
I am not God.
But I am a goddess.
I am your goddess.
Your goddess.
Azura.
You are amazing goddess.
You love your goddess.
Don't you everyone?
Your mommy goddess.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm a I'm a I'm a light weight I'm a little bit of a light weight it's been so long if
you don't drink for such a long time and you don't drink for such a long time yeah the
effects are a little or a little stronger you know but I'm not drunk because we
got to go to work today we got to go to work
now so it's staying I don't know what to I am about
what did I have I actually have the bottle right here oh my goodness I hit the
I have a bottle right here it's called Green Grape I had Green Grape sold you
I'm sorry to anyone's poor ears let me make it better
much better you feel better
are you better? are you better? sorry I hit you upside your head
is it better? do you feel better? are you better?
seriously congratulations on no longer needing a bunch of months yeah yeah I'm so happy so excited
so happy so happy so excited so happy so excited yeah yeah may I draw you if you okay you could draw me
like one of your French girls
yeah and draw me however you like as long as it's not the bloody the bloody okay
you can draw me freely send me your art I would love to see it use the tags in the
Twitter I feel so old like do you not like drink and get really tired like really sleepy
that is me am I old am I hitting am I am I old I know I'm old
hmm so it's like I finally catch you live I was missing you most of the week does it work
well I hope work has been good for you thus far and I hope you've been able to
watch some of the mods and your free time and no work can be such a bitch but
that's okay you can get through and I believe in you are you okay mama mama's fine
mama's perfectly fine
whatever demons you're fighting through I don't got no demons I'm chilling I'm fine
we're having a good time
do you buy any chance of
anything starchy or greasy a snack on I will take the other I only have cookies
I end up in a popsicle I have a strawberry pop in my hand I wasn't eat
this it's about to melt I should probably eat it so I was strawberry pop I was craving
one I don't know I had I have some chicken here to me mama me me mama do
lay me me
my
mmm
Oh no, my hands are dirty.
I have a whole bottle of sodium, I'm gonna jump on the gel now, this is my way.
I hope they don't have a problem with chicken.
I was eating chicken, I'm sorry, please forgive me.
I was eating chicken.
I had a good evening, that was good, I had a good time.
You guys were always like, oh she sounds drunk, and I was like, you haven't heard me when I'm drunk.
Fried chicken, oh I'm not really supposed to have fried chicken.
My nutritionist is gonna yell at me next week.
Have you been eating the things that I recommend to you?
You're lying, you put me lying to me, I'm so sorry.
Have you been eating those peas?
Have you been eating that white meat?
Was it white meat or red meat?
I remember.
That goes my cheat day, every day is my cheat day.
Do you wanna perish?
I like being here.
They give you that look, that questionable look.
You're joking right?
Yeah yeah yeah, it was a joke, it was a joke, it was a joke, it was a joke, it was a joke.
It was a joke, forgive me, don't write me up, please, don't write me up.
I'm eating an icy, this is an icy strawberry flavored YouTube.
Don't hit me with it, don't hit me with it, don't hit me with the hammer.
Reviving, before we gotta go to work, we gotta go to work today and work as a store owner.
It must suck to be a store owner.
I need store owners in the chat, you guys own a store.
Is it hard to keep up with everything?
Is it complicated?
No, no, no.
Yum.
Tomato, tomato, tomato, tomato, tomato, I like tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes.
Tomato, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes, tomatoes
Cocobacca, Chillabacca,
Cowbodya
Cowboy
Are you eating noodles?
I want ramen
but I can't have pockets ramen
you all might like my 말을 sounds.
I was about to flavor it.
You guys.
I'm outside for a moment.
Let me
let me
now
Now
I've had some vegan food. Vegan food isn't too bad. There was like these like meatballs
that weren't really meat and I don't know what it was made out of and I ate it and it
was so good. I don't remember. It was like whole foods I think. It was very yummy. It
was super yummy. I didn't even know it was vegan. I just picked it up and I ate it.
That was crazy.
hmm
Adora is via lawyers most intellectuals from that's right
That's right. I'm the most intellectuals we're here. I know everything is to know about anything
I'm intelligent. Mm-hmm
hmm
Mm
There's no nine of our line and we need a record with the jukebox. I'm here with you, Lele
I was a little bit late to stream though.
I had to pee pee.
If I came all of a sudden I had to go.
Um, actually.
Could have been artificial meat maybe, but it was the lesses.
I don't care what it was.
Give me more of that and just don't tell me what it was because if you tell me it was
something crazy I'll probably be sick to my stomach.
Still better than Taco Bell meat?
You know, I had Taco Bell for the first time in like 5 years.
It was actually pretty good.
I had Taco Bell so long because I used to really fuck my stomach.
Really bad.
I destroyed my stomach, but I had it recently.
It was good.
It was really good, but I couldn't finish that quesadilla.
It was uh, too much.
Too much.
Too much my stomach, not until it.
I'm a big fan of soft tacos though.
I like a soft taco.
I'm traumatized by a hard taco because I remember biting into one and then like the shell like
shanked my gum.
I remember being in so much pain and I was like nah, I'm not eating a hard taco again.
It's horrible.
I have a bad experience.
It's true, I think so.
I believe so.
Oh my gosh, that reminds me of when I got food poisoning from Mickey D.
I had heavy food poisoning, twice.
I haven't eaten anything really, but this like chicken.
Hey, just like two pieces of chicken.
That was all I had today, nothing else.
And there's icy.
No.
No bread.
I'm all out of bread.
Only bread I have is this one right here.
I want.
One double.
Oh, can't reach it.
That's too far.
Yeah, twice.
I got food poisoning at Mickey D.
I ate 20 pieces of chicken nuggets, chicken nuggets.
I ate 20 pieces and the other time I had a 40 piece.
And then I got sick.
I went to bed and I was laying on the floor because I couldn't lay on the sofa at the time
because I didn't have the actual bed.
I had a sofa.
A family member was staying over so they took my sofa and they kept kicking me so I laid on the
floor.
I was on the floor and I was sleeping and then all of a sudden my stomach was hurting.
It woke me up, but I couldn't move.
I was like paralyzed.
I couldn't move.
I couldn't get up.
I was laying there.
I was on my stomach and I woke up and I was like my head up and I was like,
whoa, I can't, I can't move.
I gotta go to the bathroom.
I can't, I can't move.
And I was like, and I almost like choked.
I had to turn over to the side, like as hard as I could.
I had to force myself to turn to the side and I was just like,
it wouldn't stop.
It was horrible.
And then after that, I didn't have Mickey D's for like three years and then I had it again later on.
Everyone was eating it.
It was the only thing I could afford at the time.
They're not when they still have the dollar menus.
Yeah, no other choice.
I was a hungry.
Mmm.
Sweet and sour sauce is good.
I like the sauce for chimkin nuggets.
I had sweet and sour sauce with my nuggets.
Mmm.
I'm going to have one more drink.
Totally not alki-hole, nothing like that.
Oh, nope, nope, nope.
And then we'll play and we'll head on over to work.
This bottle is now empty.
Ow.
Cheers to being and via Lord and and and and being Azura.
Do lay.
Cheers to you guys.
Cheers to everyone here.
You're all amazing and you are awesome and I love you very much.
And mommy cares for you and you're awesome.
So cheers, cheers to everything and the future.
Cheers.
Where do I clink this on?
I think I'll clink it on this.
Ah.
Woo.
Yeah, this is so bad.
We're going to work.
Let's get to work.
Let's get busy.
Mmm.
WOW, is Festival a fewer.
I don't know.
I don't mean to know nothing about me is cute. I'm I'm gross
I'm rock back back back
you guys like a goat
was gross
nasty
I'm gross
you
game game game game
game
game ok
I love you
turn that off
and
wait
that's the wrong button
and
woo
Pardon me? You don't hear that?
I'm ready to run my store. It has one more get simulator time. I'm gonna sell milk put I think we have to like unlock it unlock milk or something
so we have to we have to get in there and unlock our milk and sell all the cold milk there is to sell
welcome to supermarket simulator you'll start with a small store and grow to an awesome supermarket
start by purchasing goods to sell and place them onto the shelves don't forget
to set the prices with a profit to avoid bankruptcy have fun
okay thank you place you are you're so smart or AI or so smart or what's that
okay
let's sell bread bread nothing but bread how much money we have oh we only got 50
buckaroons 50 buckaroons
we're only gonna sell bread way I can't purchase it
way what can I purchase shipping four dollars fine wait they're still 83 dollars
is that always like that wait how do I get up there there's a lot of money wait it's all bread
wait there's a rail wait I lowered it purchase heck yeah bread yeah how do we like bread
bread what ah okay wait let me out let me out
hello
can you can you guys can you guys hear me what the heck just happened what the heck
I swear I have like the worst luck am I a bit laggy I'm laggy hang on give me one second I'm
I'm a laggy I'm a bit laggy
is it butter yeah it's butter
okay there we go
no did I disconnect so the I didn't purposely disconnect it it like turned off
it turned off by itself and it was like reconnecting reconnecting reconnecting reconnecting
reconnecting and it was like boop boop boop beep beep boop boop boop boop boop boop oh
every time I play anything or games I have like the worst luck
I don't think I don't think technology likes me very much
I don't think technology likes me
is that a bread
and proud proud proud and proud reconnecting to these nuts to these nuts
I reconnect all these nuts
I'm an expensive goddess
how did I wait we're gonna make it five bucks oh that's not five bucks
yeah yeah yeah five bucks for bread open
how do I use this oh I hold it no it doesn't work how do I use this
oh bro just one just one bro you get no change change oh give me 10
there you go there you go I can math I can math I swear I can math
I can math what just one bro
bam boom let's get it making that bread
bread literally bread oh yeah
bam proud
proud
proud hug it off give me off I want to be free oh
oh well oh don't be shy that's okay that's a wrap take your bread you're so so tall
I so I'm so tall
geez he's so tall oh hello look at fine over there lady like a blue everything blue
yeah super blue she's a blue yeah
I'm here bro you have a piece of my bread
where is everyone oh I didn't even see him come in
everyone's just buying one bread buy more no change goodbye bye bye
give me off I want I want to be free I want to be free free release me release me release release me
release me release me how do I oh back oh ha I'm free
more bread
yeah
I should walk and then like that that whole sway
sway swagger swagger swagger is that still a saying or am I too old
says to the same
yeah swagger
swag oh I just buy one bread
hmm
am I all hip hip hip like yeah hip like the cool kids as they say I'm so hip
oh all my shoulders
oh that was a nice pop was like
for what why would you give me $50 for $5 bread why why
there you go
for your name and a dollar there you go bro don't have a change it's crazy
hello welcome to the stream everybody I hope you're having a wonderful day and you're all have
a feeling
feeling good and stuff sorry my my chest started to feel funny I had a double check
huh
hi
is that a drinking a solitarist drinking together drinking together having a drink
having a good time having a good time
she didn't buy bread can you believe that she's left how dare she
like what else do you need besides bread you don't need anything else just bread
bread and milk and that's what we're gonna sell bread and milk you don't need anything else how
dare she
how dare she is dark that's dark in here wait
how do I get out again release me oh escape right away
it's too expensive well go get your cheap bread somewhere else
haha late camera
the disrespect they come here and expect to get some cheap bread
they're getting bread from a goddess and they think that it will be like a dollar
only high quality bread here all right the highest of the highest the best bread of the best
it's the best bread of the best bread of the best bread of the best bread it is now 9 p.m
oh there's a person what we're closed what the hell are you doing in here get out
get out what the why are you in here get out we're closed we're closed oh
wow you could stay you could stay can you stay tonight if you want to
do
thanks kind of look like a little bit of Taylor Swift so tiny bit
no no just me
anybody else anyone else now why she walk like that she was so funny
dang
so i know she got something up there you know
you have to close the door
so
and now working and now working
dang
wait how do you how do you leave wait oh but space no and and enter enter enter
oh not that enter button this one oh ha ha i did it i did it end of the day
you get two bread you want two bread i gave you two bread i got two bread for you
i got two breads for you
ha ha
sorry daily expensive you'll receive daily bills starting today make sure to buy the bills
using your computer before their due date or they'll be paid automatically the more electrical
devices the more expensive the bills
okay thank you thank you thank you
oh
let's talk
brother for you coming up
well thank you for the uh for the ten dollars don't know by the way i forgot to thank you
thank you
the third meaner third mean third mean terminator
sir my name is her sir my day
so thank you sir my name is her for the ten dollars thank you thank you and thank you oh
i don't know most i don't know most i don't know most for the four dollars thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you
money money money money money money money money money so much but i like to play
funds for the best mama ever
uh what oh thank you thank you thank you uh i'll for fun i'll for fun all for fun all for fun thank you
for the five dollars i don't know thank you thank you thank you thank you
we have to have three more breath and then breath yeah like breath more breath
thank you thank you
i want so much breath got any milk got any grapes
any water no way water water i know why are you away why are y'all
i know why are you away why are y'all
got any grapes
i like an open store
i should know the bread i know your bread
hey
yeah that's right you grabbed that brun you grabbed that oh two breves you know what he wants
it
hehe
...thousand dollars
10 dollars
hehe
...de-de-de-de-ake
de-de-de-de-de-de
hey hey hey hey
where are the people?
we're the customers hey do you guys want any water oh gosh where's the water
area water
I just spilled it everywhere
won't pretend that it didn't happen
won't pretend that it did not happen
that's right everyone don't forget to hydrate
don't forget to hydrate drink your agua
hey
excuse me I don't want burp on swim I swim I swim I swim and I stream stream
stream so I'm ladylike so ungood
Hehehe
authano coz
They like my brother
should I turn on the
BM. Do you guys want medium and the background is a quiet
I don't know, but the bad bit the
bit down
bitch, bitch, yeah
sounds like a white fart
I turn it up, it's a little bit
let's come play
let me out
let me go
market head, market, market head
what are we buying?
none of these
bank licenses
oh we can get, we need $200
we need level 3, we need $200 and level 3
and we can get milk
I'm so excited
yeah, level 3 and we get milk
we're so close, so close
brudden buns, brudden buns
I like buns too
you know my favorite part of a check
or I mean check-in
my favorite part of a check is
thighs
I love me some thighs
check-in, check-in thighs
insufficient form
I really like me some thighs
give me that back, give me that back
it's nice, my dollar
brud
I can get milk
wait, oh wait
that's $200, I need 100 more buckaroons
expensive
have fun with your cheapo store
that sells cheapo milk and brud
that tastes like cardboard
lame
our brud is of the best kind
I tell you
it's the best of the best
and you should have it, have at you
where is everybody
hey, I'm open
oh, oh
ha ha ha ha
oh, hello
yeah, that's right
ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha
bye, have a nice day
hope to see you again
ha ha ha ha
Two bridge hi Trevor how you doing?
He's still not close yet
Oh
My eyeballs
You know my favorite part of a sigh, you know you know when you know long stockings
You know when they're like really tight and they got that little plump
Little plump to it
Just I just want to
Yeah
Isn't there this artist that makes food out of like makes clothes out of food
Like candy and then the like models wear it
I'd eat that I eat that I
Eat that they don't have to take it off
I eat it right off
We didn't make 200 bug barons we're broke. How do you close again? Oh
Start next day start next day
But
I have no clue why that popped into my head, but about into my head
What did I pop into my head?
The period about the taxes
He taxes
Taxi
Who doesn't like taxes?
Two taxes, stupid.
Stupid taxes.
I hate taxes.
You're welcome, Forgotten Memories.
You're gonna experience that a lot here.
Two breads.
Sure.
I'll see you.
Hey, you tall guy.
You back again.
How you doing?
Have a nice day.
So a big boy.
A big boy.
Big boy.
Massive boy.
But no matter how big you are,
you'll always be a big boy.
you'll always be small to me.
Wow.
You have nice hair.
It's kind of like doing a little
light show for me.
Kind of.
T-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t-t.
I'm sorry.
My apologies.
Ooh, a whole white suit.
Brass fancy.
Fancy.
Oh.
Fancy two breads.
I like them when they get two breads.
You know, you can't...
You gotta make sure you pay attention
to the other one, you know?
So it's always two.
Bye-bye.
Hi, girl. How you doing?
Got a little weird...
Is that a bed head?
A little thing going on over there.
Right there.
Come.
I guess it's kind of cute.
It's kind of cute like you.
Kind of endearing.
Kind of cute.
Bye-bye.
Dang, that skirt snatched.
Life seems rough.
I hope it gets better.
I'm gonna say...
Ooh.
Thank you.
I'm gonna say...
How you doing?
Feel like a bartender?
Like in your bar or something?
Can I get milk now?
I want milk.
How do I get it?
How do I get milk?
I...
Management.
Licenses.
Purchase.
Milk, milk, milk, milk.
What the heck?
I just have a marker.
Milk, milk, milk.
Milk.
Bar.
Wait, do I need a fridge?
How much is a fridge?
Oh boy.
Okay.
We got this.
Yeah, yeah.
Gotta make that buck runny.
When you gave me a hundred dollars.
Five, five, two...
Alright, Walter.
My apologies.
Let's pretend...
I said nothing.
Go ahead and take that.
And...
Complete a 50...
Ouch!
Have a nice day, Walter.
My bad, my bad.
Probably needs that.
Buck runies, you know.
Probably only got 100 buck runies.
Thanks for shopping.
Bye-bye.
Five dollars!
One dollar.
More friends!
Everything's so...
I'm getting,
I'm getting...
Getting hit with a...
A-ba!
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba!
this reminds me of when I was working um cashier I told you about the internet
about my finger right 90 dollars I can't I had to tell you about my finger yeah it
was a whole accident it was a big complete accident you know how so they
like they back then I don't know if they do it the same but you know how you know
how when um uh you would uh you work at the cashier but every employee had their
own um little banky so we would have to take it out we would take the whole thing
out and we'd take it with us to each register every time we go to a new register so we all
had our own little banky that we were in charge of and the finger in the safe yeah yeah that one
yeah so it would we so every time you would run out of money or something or something that you need
change for you'd give them the big bills and then they would go into the safe and give you like
smaller bills and stuff so that you can like give change to the customer and stuff and I
um they would take it expensive bye trevor bye bye
uh much money oh so they would like give you change that you would need to um
uh give give give to the customer and I went to go give get change and they put the bill
like on the edge on top of the safe while it was open and I went to grab it like I went to like
reach up to grab it and they closed the door of the safe like a giant metal safe
they closed it and it's not one where you put in a coat or anything they closed it on my finger
on my thumb because my thumb was hanging off you know like when you grab something you slide it
off slowly you could do it on the table right now and see how it is when you slide it grab it
and then you slide it so my thumb was hanging off of this of the safe and they closed it right on my
finger thank goodness she didn't um the uh they didn't close it all the way on my finger like it
didn't completely close or it probably would have been worse but they managed to open it back up
really quickly uh before it closed fully but my finger was shamushed it was split in two
hey the big two
hey and next day it was split in two
working there was a nightmare it was a nightmare do you have a scar I have a small one
it's tiny it's not very visible um they didn't even have like a first aid kit
and my boss was like just slap a bandaid on it and get back to work I was like oh okay
I was like I didn't scream or anything you know adrenaline rushed in and I was really I was the
calmest while everyone else was freaking out I was so calm super calm yeah
and then um I had to walk because they didn't want to call anyone to come get me so I had to walk to
the hospital on foot I had to walk I wish I knew I was really young so I wish I knew about you
know suing and stuff but two years already passed more than two years that's so long I don't like
it way more than two years has passed so I think there's like a you can't really uh
so anyone after two two two years I think it's the thingy so I didn't know what I just moved on
past it and ever since then I just hated that place they did more and more things that really
made me upset so I had to walk to the hospital and they got like uh they put like skin glue
on me uh and they had to like shift the finger they have to shift it
for it to realign itself and then they stuck it together they smushed it together and then they
put skin glue on it to keep it together
so
yeah
and then they healed they healed after that had a big old band-aid and a big old band-aid it was
like a big wrap around it
and
yeah I think that's it wasn't worse it could be like what happened to a what do you say
I don't got nothing else for you get out yeah we don't sell sugar maybe
I got some sort of sugar for you
ah
it could be worse it could have been worse with my finger because I think the person who got it
the worst was um a family member of mine we had a doggie
we had a doggie and doggie was tied to the door the front door and
and family member decided to open door with doggie still tied to door and doggie loves outdoor
loves outdoors you know loves out being outdoors and doggie slipped through the crack of the door
and pulled the door shut
and family member
lost finger
finger was hanging on by skin
um so it could have been worse
I remember being traumatized by that I had it took me a long a long time to get over that scene
that I saw I saw with my eyeballs it was like all over the wall it was red over the wall
specks and dots and yada yada it was a it was a very gruesome sight
it's very gruesome it's a long line hey how you guys doing
how you doing
I like your pants like your belt
hey it's it's her again I love the dress looks nice on you
hey buddy buddy how you doing it's your chunky you're so cute look at me so chunky and so cute
I want to a splash
chunky and so cute look at him go he's a big boned boy big boned boy big boned boy
get out get out there's nothing else here for you I need a fridge hang on
give me a fridge thanks yeah now we're gonna get milk we can sell milk now
how much how much should I sell the milk for how much how much wait
we gotta look at that market price
66 dollars and 90 cents
six dollars and nine percent hey 69 69
my right index finger is shorter than my left index finger dog got into a car
I said what else would see a bit apart of my finger
I was actually bit by my dog before
but not on purpose I did a dumb thing my dog she decided to eat a bone off the floor
and me being the kid that I was was stupid and I put my finger in her mouth trying to take it out
and she bit through my index finger like through it like I didn't lose my finger it just went
through the finger it's the best kind of milk ma'am the best kind
so that was my bad I should have never put my hand in her mouth should have just left to be
bye bye
and I think they're gonna buy my milk they're not gonna buy my milk I think the milk is too expensive
they're not buying my milk they don't like my milk and bread it's too expensive
we're gonna be broke we need to make it cheaper
you know what I think it's good good price I think it's good price
I say your entire stock now they don't want my milk
I got you all right it's fine it's fine
that should be good right
I
want some dollars give me some money
you guys will buy my milk you guys like my milk I got plenty plenty more where that came from
I
buy my milk
I had video games, video games, video games, video games.
I have so good at the video games, video games, I am so good at it.
I like me games, you like me games.
Are we closed?
Next day.
We're gonna play it up in here.
Then we stalk ourselves.
Oh, welcome.
Welcome baby.
Stalker here.
Sailing on Nero.
Loud, loud, loud.
How is it still expensive?
Where are you going?
We have bread to look brother.
Come back.
Where are you going to get?
Bread?
Do you have bread?
No!
Get the milk?
You like milk?
No!
Please!
Please be back.
It's good I swear.
Yeah brother.
What do you need water for?
You have milk.
Do you need water?
Water?
The fuck is water?
We don't have nothing else in here for you.
Get out!
It's only bread and milk.
Bread and milk.
What do you want?
I only want the milk.
I got big old milkers for them.
Big old milkers.
I got the milk for you.
I got the milk.
No!
What do you mean?
It's perfect.
Let's do it.
Why?
Just buy it!
I don't understand it's the best price it's it's straight from me
thank you so much i'm glad you like my singing voice and why you like my voice so
you would get my milk i'm happy thank you so much for the four dollar don't know
anonymous thank you thank you thank you thank you
he has a swag
can you get the milk though or a broky bro it's all right i understand
but it's a it's a hard it's a hard world out there it's hard
i'm really hard out there maybe singing stream i want to do karaoke karaoke sounds fun i'm only
nervous of uh i'm nervous whoa excuse me of what songs i'm allowed to sing live you know
i'm a little bit nervous just a little bit nervous
okay i know just a little bit i'm fine i'm not sleepy i'm not sleepy i'm good i'm good don't
worry about me don't worry about me what's a box
don't know what that is are you me and uh
stay no
no
i love your suit sure
why does no one want to want my milk
why
away
oh i am
whoa there is no cheese wait we can have cheese hang on a minute
cheers i am i have to reconsider cheese fine but it's already at like two dollars
like how much cheaper do you want it what is this treachery i like that song that's my favorite
ost in bleach treachery so 99 is all you get all right buy the damn milk it's not that hard
someone bought milk okay who bought milk
i don't remember seeing you buy milk
da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da
like treachery cheers there's cheers looky
as bleach ost treachery it's one of one of my favorites i like another one as well but i don't
remember the name for it he bought milk thank you he likes my milk
it's a good day
all right is that the one is that the right one
i'm gonna play ost three is that fine
treachery
uh
is that loud i don't want to speak too loud
um
Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha
Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Nobody more scared
Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha
Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha
DAESUI's
I
Buy another fridge. I have 37 bucks all broke. Oh
We're gonna go bankrupt. Oh
You bought milk nice
Yeah, I knew they like my milk. I
Know they like my milk
I
Wait, I knew they like my milk
To brats and the milk
Indeed very fast
We may have lowered the price of two brats
Get out. There's nothing here for you. You suck
It's nothing here. You're broke you can't even afford milk and brad
It's definitely all goat milk 100% goat milk
Go to milk
Oh
Is there such thing as cheese made from goat goat milk, why do I keep jumping? Oh, I'm holding the space bar
What's the other oh, how many milk does she get two of each a girl I
See you. Don't look at me like that. Don't look away. I'm like you shy
I got you
I'm sad you feel
How nice day whoo she was looking for oil to
Oil it up to milk for two milkers
You need a cashier on your own yeah, I got a dream man
I'm hitting on the customers. Well, you're one of my customers too. No, you come pretty frequently for my milk
I
Mean like come on come over to a store and you buy it milk
my milk
This milk in town
Wait
I
Like to buy her entire stock of milk. Yes, please buy it buy it all
By every single bit of that
We run out of bread. There's no bread. We need more bread
two four six eight
Who do we appreciate?
Wait, oh wait, don't need to buy other stuff. We should we should calm down on the on the bread
You want to use to I love to use
However invented cheese as a genius
Like who comes up with cheers who like just let milk spoil and then was like
Wonder what this tastes like. What is this?
And then was like
Amazing like how did how do they do that? There's no way be too scared
Oh
Jesus the boom I love me some cheese
I
Now that's gonna be stuck in my head really forever. I
Wonder what the other song is. Oh, it's this one. I like this one. This is my other one. That's my other favorite one
It's called Invasion.
It's my other favorite list here.
Yeah, I like that one.
It's my other favorite one.
I have a customer.
I need to buy a fridge.
I want a duck.
Duck?
I'm turning ducks.
That's a lot of chickens.
Look at all those chickens.
I like, wait, hang on.
So we're going to sell bread, cheese, and milk.
Bread, bread, cheese, and milk.
I'm going to make my own bread and my own cheese.
I want to play Sonic.
I want to play the old Sonic.
I want to play a lot.
Welcome in everyone who came in.
I hope you all had a good day at work, school, wherever you're coming from and had a great day.
Welcome in.
You're not late.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's perfectly fine.
I love you.
Welcome in.
You know the old.
Oh, hang on.
I got it.
Excuse me.
I didn't hear that.
I think I got a, I think I got a, I think I just drank some water.
I think I just drank water.
Mmm.
I don't, I don't feel so good.
I don't feel so good.
Oh my gosh.
I hope that I found it.
I am feeling about, about to, I don't know.
It's a long line.
Oh boy.
We're fine.
I am okay.
I think I'm okay.
I drank a whole bottle.
An entire whole bottle of green grape soju.
I had a whole bottle.
The discovery of cheese was by accident and bit the first cheese to taste tested.
I was probably consumed because it's like, well, that milk was the only thing I had for food.
And then ate it for survival.
True.
I think that's probably what happened.
You know the first sonic?
You know the very first sonic?
Not the very first sonic.
You know the one.
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
When you're underwater and you butt it down.
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
I remember what sonic with that was.
That's the first one really?
I want to play that.
That was like the best ADHD game ever.
I want to play that. It's not fair. Where is it? I can't find it anywhere. I don't think
we can play Sonic on stream though, I don't think.
Wasn't it?
Why not? I don't think we can even find that game. I don't think. I don't think you can really find
that. I don't think you're gonna be able to find that at all on PC. Give me.
So sorry. I'm a little gassy. I'm so sorry. Oh, so unclassy. So unladylike.
I'm a little gassy.
No
Oh
Blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
Sonic 2? I like the Sonic games a lot. I used to play them a lot when I was a
kid. However, I wasn't allowed to play. I was second player. You know that kid
that had the remote control that wasn't actually plugged in. I was second
player. I wasn't allowed to play. But I was a pretty smart kid so I knew that I
wasn't playing the game. So I figured it out really fast. I didn't complain though.
Rest in peace. I'm God!
I'm back.
Gas! See, I wasn't passing that kind of gas. I was just belching. I was just belching.
What do you mean? I have a different sound. I was like lagging a little bit. Sorry, I'm
catching up. I did a little bit of crashy. You know, I still have my Xbox 360. I've
had it for years. I still have it and it works. I have a bunch of Xbox 360 games.
Let me see. Let me look up at my bookshelf. Left 4 Dead 2, Payday 2. Does that be
jeweled? I said Arkham, Arkham, Arkham, Arkham Asylum Batman. I have Assassin's Creed
Brotherhood and Assassin's Creed. What other Assassin's Creed? The first one?
Assassin's Creed 2. I have Sims, pets. Oh no, it's PC. That's a PC disc. Why is that
in the middle of there? I have BioShock, BioShock Infinite, Call of Duty Black Ops 2. I have
another Assassin's Creed. I think I bought two because one disc wasn't working. Assassin's
Creed 4? Is that what that says? Grand Theft Auto? Grand Theft Auto? Yeah. Then I have another
Call of Duty Black Ops 2 disc because the other one wasn't working. I have Destiny. I never really
played it. Destiny. Final Fantasy X2. And then everything else is GameCube games. A bunch of
GameCube games at PlayStation 2 games. I haven't been up there on that shelf in like four years.
Everything's just been sitting up there.
Yeah, my Xbox still works. I took kind of good care of it. I haven't received the red thing,
red ring of death yet. It's still good. Still working. My other one used to turn on by itself.
Actually, I think this is the one. If it's not unplugged, it turns on by itself. I don't know
why, but it turns on by itself. If you leave it plugged in, it will just turn on. I think that's
the only thing wrong with it. All my other games are long gone.
And then I have the Naruto Ultimate Ninja for PlayStation 2. I have all of them,
except for one because someone stole it. I had Chronicles as well.
I don't have four because I came out after I got the whole pack series.
Then I have Storm Chronicles as well. I have the first Sims and Sims 2.
I have the Brats. I remember getting that for my birthday long time ago. The Brats.
It was a really fun game for Gamecube and Road Rage, the Simpsons Road Rage. I have that too.
So enough there.
Yeah, games up there. Everything else broke, so everything else had to go in the trash.
A lot of CD discs broke. I had Super Smash Bros for Gamecube. Both discs broke.
My favorite Pokemon game was Colosseum. Pokemon Colosseum was my favorite one. Was it Pokemon
Colosseum? It was. Haha. It was my favorite Pokemon game. I played that on Gamecube.
I played that like five times before it broke.
A family member of mine thought that they could fix the Gamecube and they ended up
breaking it further by taking it apart, so I could never play it again. Then they broke the
discs to the Smash Bros and Colosseum.
Any Kirby? I didn't get to play Kirby. I was only allowed to watch, sadly.
I was a brokey growing up, so I could only get my hands on so much. The majority of the games
that I got was free. People who were done playing it and didn't want it anymore,
so I was very lucky to be able to play a lot of the games. I think there was this one scary game
with aliens or something on PlayStation 2. Extermination? I think it was called extermination.
I don't have that anymore either. I used to play that too. I think it was the only scary game that
I could stomach besides Resident Evil 6? Six and four? Or was it three? No, not three.
Which one's the one with silver in it?
Which one's that one? Which one was that one in Resident Evil?
Five? Resident Evil 5? Yeah, that's the one. I can only play Resident Evil 5 and 6. It wasn't
scary. It wasn't too scary for me. Don't have a lot of jump scares. Do I have a Wii? I do have a Wii.
My favorite game to play on the Wii was the Michael Jackson game. It kept me fit.
I knew all the dances, all the dance moves. I still do.
I remember playing the dance games on the Gamecube 2. We had the little dance pad,
the little plastic dance pad. You step on it. I remember that too. We had that too.
Good night to anyone heading to bed. Have a sweet dream. Thank you for stopping by. Appreciate you.
Is that real? It came with a Michael's glove? I think so. I don't remember.
I don't remember the glove. We had the game for so long. I don't remember.
It was really fun dancing to it. I would literally do that over stream.
But I don't think we can play any other songs on stream. I don't think. I don't think.
My first zombie game was Left 4 Dead. My first zombie game was Left 4 Dead too. I have it right up there.
That was my very first game that I played. It was Left 4 Dead.
Do you have Gamecube games to play it on? Do you have a Gamecube to play it on? No.
I no longer have one. I haven't had one for over 10 years. It's been 10 years.
I have one in a minute.
That was one in a minute.
I still have my remote controls though. I have an orange one and a gray one.
Had a purple one. I don't know where that went. Disappeared.
I still have my orange remote. It was my favorite remote.
Yeah, I still have it sitting right there.
Do I have Gamecube games? Yeah, I do. I have the Bratz and Road Rage. The Simpsons Road Rage.
Those are my only two Gamecube games I still have. I lost the Colosseum game. That was broken long time ago.
Oh, and I have the Michael Jackson game.
My mom is a little bit of a gamer, but I highly doubt that she'll let me touch her Mario game.
I do not think she'll let me touch it.
She bit me up.
Highly doubt she'll let me touch that.
She plays that like every day.
She plays her Super Mario game every day. I think they got the newest one too.
Oh, I forgot I was writing the story. I guess I'm golfing story time.
Ah, I have two milks, one bread.
I am via fritz now.
Purchase. I ran up with our cheese in it.
How much is she as? Oh, we can sell it for five dollars. She does it expensive. What the hell?
I missed the crabs now.
Yeah, Pokemon Colosseum is my favorite Pokemon game for a long time.
Ah, I'm starting to get hit with the sleeps. I'm going to eat me really fast. I feel so old.
I would love to play Left 4 Dead with the girls. That sounds so fun.
It's like a trip down memory lane. Like hardcore. Hardcore down memory lane.
Yeah, I remember. I remember playing Final Fantasy a long time ago.
I remember it like it was yesterday. I didn't have a bed. I didn't have a bed frame. I didn't own one.
I stopped on the floor. The hard floor. I remember. We had those big bulky TVs.
You know, the old TVs. Big bulky TVs. I had to play PlayStation 2.
That was the first time I got to play a game really, myself, to myself that I owned.
I remember I was given Final Fantasy X2 as a gift and I used to watch all the Final Fantasy games.
I really like Final Fantasy and I think someone in my family was like, I heard you like this game.
I don't know which one this is, but here's this one and it gave it to me and I played it.
I never got to finish that game. Never got to finish it.
There I got to finish it because the disc was scratched in a specific spot.
A really small specific spot was damaged on the disc.
So whenever I got near the ending of the game, it would freeze.
The crash and freeze. I'd start over mainly because I didn't have a memory disc.
So I had to play the game from the start because I didn't own a memory disc. All my other memory
discs were lost or stolen. So I started the game over from the start and I would play all the way
through because I thought maybe it was just an issue with something and I'd play it all the way
through and I'd get to that concert part. The concert. Never got to get to you.
Never got to you. And then the game crashes. I realized that it was just a scratch on the disc
and I was never going to be able to finish it. That was a good game though.
I did the same thing with Pokemon Colosseum as well. I finished the game and then someone
lent me their, I had the disc still. Someone lent me their Gamecube and I got to play the game but
I had to like zoom through it because I didn't have a memory disc. So I had to play it again
one last time. That person was very nice and I gave them back their Gamecube. I was very happy.
They lent me play one last time.
I was so excited to get my first job.
When I was crazy, my first job was actually this job. It was the job where I hurt my finger.
That was my very first job. My very first official job.
I was so happy. I bought so many things. I bought this disc that I still have but unfortunately
I messed up and I didn't realize that this disc was actually a dinner table.
This is why I have a dinner table disc.
So my clamp on for the for the my microphone stand thingy is like barely hanging on because
this is not properly clamped because the outside part like comes out.
That's why I added a desk on the the thingy. I think I mentioned this before how I just add
I add random things due to what I like experienced or went through. Like I could tell you a story
almost all the things I added onto that list of things on the throne.
So it was the first time I got that job and I started buying like I was saving up as much
about this desk. I bought me a like a bed frame my first bed frame. I was lent the mattress.
One gave me a mattress so I still have that mattress to this day.
I got my first dresser because I never had a dresser.
I had an old one and my cat used to sleep in it. He used to pull it open and he
will sleep at the bottom of it. I had a little table. I got my first TV.
All of that with this job and these bookshelves and stuff.
Then after that I saved up as much as possible and I got my first PC.
I broke my motherboard to that PC though. It was an accident. It was my first time really like
doing stuff with a PC. It was my very first time and I snapped my motherboard in half.
I didn't know about like unscrewing stuff and how to move stuff. I thought I unscrewed it
really well and I was like moving stuff and then I like pulled on it. I'm like maybe I have to like
pull on it a little more and I pulled on it and it's like I'm like
okay and then after that I broke. I got another PC and I broke my graphics card.
I yanked that out because the first one was really hard to come out so I thought it was
going to be the same for the next one and I just yanked it out and the part that's usually like
clamped in on the thingy came off and came off the graphics card.
And then the fans broke on it too so that's the reason why I was taking it out. I was
going to try and replace the fans but then it ended up where I had to replace the whole thing.
How expensive was that mistake? I was really broke so I had to, I was saving up a lot of
money to get new parts so I had to use the money that I was saving up to get a new computer which
only cost me like 800, 899 dollars. I got it on Black Friday. It was a Black Friday. I got it
right after Thanksgiving. I got it on a Black Friday. Well, Cyber Monday. They call it Cyber
Monday. It's people who can't really go out on Black Friday so yeah I got it like 899 dollars.
It was on sale. It was on sale. It was a really cheap computer.
I still got it though it's falling apart and it's what I was streaming with
before this for a while. I had to take off the glass because it was overheating and I needed
to put a fan and like facing it to blow on it. It was overheating really bad. My CPU was bad.
Everything was bad. It was falling apart. I still got it. I was really surprised.
I was really happy when Strony found me and Strony found me. I had like the worst equipment.
So when everyone says, when everyone's really confused about why my audio and everything's
so bad now, I had horrible equipment before this. I have no clue how to work this equipment.
I'm so new to using all this stuff. It's so technical. I'm just like
yeah yeah yeah yeah but I'm pretty nerdy and geeky in the sense where I like to study this
stuff so I watched a bunch of videos learning how to work stuff. I'm learning. It's going to take
me time though. I had the worst equipment. So I'm very happy. Strony saved me.
Literally just before, just before things went down and I got the email. Two of my fans stopped
working. Two of my fans stopped working. The fans on my graphics card. One of the fans wouldn't spin.
She has saved me. She has saved me.
She sent me up really good.
My monitors were like breaking slowly. The color in the monitors were leaving.
It was bad. I was the brokest of the brokest. I have tape on everything. I currently have tape
on my chair. She can only help me put so much. I think I mentioned this.
She can only help me put so much.
My milk is really selling. I really like my milk.
All milk.
It's nice to meet all of you. I know there is new of you in here and stuff so I want to say
welcome and I hope you find it nice and cozy and you like and enjoy your stay here. We have
a mix of vibes here. They're really the same. So I hope you understand.
I am milk and bread. I'm getting a little bit. I even have a little bit. A lot of
bit a little bit.
Is this someone's birthday?
It's my it's my it's my mother fucking birthday today. Wow it's your birthday. Hang on a second.
Is it your birthday?
It's my birthday.
Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday. Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear bread. Happy birthday to you.
Have a good one. I hope you enjoy your birthday.
I would never.
I'm glad to be here. I'm happy that you're here too.
I'm very happy that you're here. I'm glad that all of you are here. Thank you all for being here.
All of your bird support. You're all sweet and I appreciate you all very much. Please leave.
Yeah I like that. Goat cheers. Goat cheers. Goat milk. Yeah grab it. That's right.
Yeah.
This game is fun. It's very like the fun game you just play on the side when you're especially
when you're not all up there in the head. This is a great game to play especially when you're not
all up there in the head. You just relax and play this game and enjoy your time.
Look at your shirt. I want to touch his forehead. It looks like it looks like it'll be soft.
Oh that'll be soft. I'll touch you. Poke at it.
Poke poke. Travis is back. They are.
My head is hurting. My head is starting to hurt.
Water. I don't need water.
Whoa.
Whoa. I had green grab. Green grab. So joy. It was good. Very yummy.
Yeah.
I have other. I have two more soju. I don't think it's good. I didn't drink it right now.
I wanted to save it for another special occasion.
Oh. Well.
Taking money back. You can take your money back by right clicking on the bills in the
cash register. Thank you. I'll just take that. Thank you.
I think this will be the last day for this game.
We'll get through this day and we'll just stop and chat it up for a bit.
Last day, last day.
I'm, I'm, yippee, like, yippee.
Well, I think it's my headphones.
Do you guys ever get, like, these, like, crazy headaches from your headphones being on your
head for too long?
And here's my headphones.
They, like, squishing my head.
My head is being, like, squished, squished, and I'm hot, I'm so hot.
Oh, get this off me!
Are you ever fine?
Oh.
Oh, it's so hot.
I'm burning.
Oh my god.
Oh, I hate clothes.
Why wear clothes?
Clothes is unnecessary.
You don't need a...
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay, I'm sorry if this fan...
Oh, it's too high.
Are you?
Oh, okay.
It gets boiling in my room.
You don't understand.
If you guys didn't help me get this fan, I would have been melting in here.
Like, like, this is what I was used to, this is what I had to deal with.
I would sweat, like, no tomorrow, and I usually don't sweat.
I sweat in random places, like, the bitties and stuff, you know?
It would sweat, like, crazy.
And my armpit, and that's it.
I wouldn't sweat anywhere else.
My forehead, don't sweat.
I'm dry everywhere else.
So I don't know why, but I sweat everywhere else, like, under the bubba, under bubba, would
sweat, crazy.
It gets so hot in here.
Oh, man.
Well, I kind of, like, technically I suffer from headaches 24-7, so I'm, like, it could
just be, like, a, you know, like, an addition, you know what I mean?
Like, an addition, an additional pain, since, you know, I suffer from headaches all the time.
So, like, the combination of the half-ones and everything else just, like, sucks.
Well.
Oh, we passed the day.
Hello, for today, for playing, uh, for playing, for playing, um, was the game called again?
Supermarket, oh, my stomach, Supermarket Simulator, yeah.
We'll chat for a bit, don't worry, but if you guys got to go, that's understandable.
But I'm done with Supermarket for now.
I'm done with the Supermarket, for the time being.
Uh, yeah, I won't be a bigger, I'm too small to make me bigger.
But, uh, yeah, I like that, and it's gonna, uh, but, uh, it's a very chill game, I like it.
So if you guys made it this far into the stream by Azura, by Azura, by Azura, is it you?
Staying next to me?
This fan has been a blessing.
Your offering of this fan was the best, the best offering ever.
It feels so good, so good.
Oh, uh, ah, if you're gonna go shower, enjoy your nice hot, steamy shower.
You're gonna go shower and show you a nice hot steamy shower.
It's all good for a mommy, oh yeah, oh yeah, you smell great, oh yeah, that's good, it's
real good yeah
how long do you guys take showers for? how long are your showers actually I'm
curious wait are you like showers for like 30 minutes 20 minutes 5 minutes 10
10 15 20 30 15 45 by the 10 by the 10 12 20 20 between button of 10 also I'm
saying like average 15 minutes so average 15 minutes you guys shower for you
wonder how long I show her for
how long I show her for? can you guess? can you guess how long I show her for?
can you guess? 1 hour? 1 hour?
What if I'm in? 4h? 4h? 4h? 4h? 4hr? 4hr? 2019???
do I hurt her?
hmm
someone was right someone was right only one person was right yeah two hours two
hours two to three hours two to three hours I saw her for like two to three
hours
For your water balance
That's fine
Don't worry about that
That's, that's fine, that's covered, that's okay.
I'm a little bit ipsy, but I'm coming off it.
I'm hungry and I haven't really eaten anything
except for this chicken.
And my stomach is like,
growling at me right now.
I'm really hungry.
I wanna order food, but I don't think it's a wise idea.
I got the bill leaves coming up.
I got the bills coming up.
And my, my mama Dulay left again.
She left, she's not here again, so I'm gonna starve.
My source of food is gone.
You stand in your shower, not me.
I sit in my shower like a psychopath.
I can't stand for long.
I can't even stand for longer than like 10 minutes, bro.
My spine hurts, I guess it's down.
I sit down and I let it run on me like,
a blasting hot boiling water right on my chest.
The water feels so good, it makes my legs wobble.
So I gotta sit down.
Go sit down.
Yo, my stomach is like,
I wish I could like, I wish you could like hear it.
I wish I could like bring you to it so you could hear it.
It is going.
I ate some cereal.
Maybe that'll just sum up my hunger.
Yeah, here it goes.
Ah, no!
Ah, I got it.
Can't waste a single piece of cereal.
We brokeie brokeie, we can't waste a single piece.
It almost fell.
Mm.
Sitting in the shower is nasty work.
Hey, I cleaned the shower.
I wiped that, that I've wiped that bitch down real good,
all right?
If I clean it, it's clean enough for me, all right?
I have OCD.
Whoa, thank you, thank you so much
for the food all the time, thank you, thank you.
If I clean my shower, it's clean, all right?
I understand how people feel though,
about not wanting to shower in other people's showers.
Feel a little dirty.
I know that feeling.
My shower is good, right?
I clean it.
The bathroom is like my safe haven.
I spend the most time on there.
Oh, yeah.
I sit on a toilet watching memes for like,
for like three hours.
Oh.
Mm-hmm.
I didn't think about life.
I bring my phone with me.
I'm really sad when I forget my phone.
I get really sad, I'm like, no, no memes.
No.
Mm-hmm.
I know you start reading stuff off of like,
bottles, ingredients off the bottles.
Mm-hmm.
Showering in other people's showers
is how you get foot fungus?
Ew.
You ain't gonna get that in my shower.
Not with my family's OCD.
You know how many times a week my,
my,
mama delay cleans?
Do you know how many times?
Yeah, I don't think you have to worry about foot fungus.
Mm-hmm.
No, I think it's an average amount of time that you clean.
She cleans every time she uses it.
Every time she uses the bathroom, she cleans it.
No.
I do the same thing.
I also clean it before I use it.
I wipe the seat down.
I don't want my poor, soft, sensitive skin touching the
seats that someone else sat on.
I'm nervous.
So I clean it every time before I sit on it.
Mm-hmm.
Mm.
Thank you, thank you for the $2 to help.
Thank you, I'm not a mouse.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh.
Thinking about life as reserve for the shower.
I think about some ratchet things in the shower.
Mm-hmm.
My imagination runs wild.
Sometimes I even bring my iPad with me.
iPad and put it on a little stand.
And I watch things in the shower.
Mm-hmm.
Yes, you may, you may use my lap.
You can use my lap.
I'm always sitting in chat.
Mm-hmm.
Shower iPad is wild.
Oh, man.
Man, I'm bored, I get bored.
Did you get bored taking a shower?
I'm bored, I gotta bring some entertainment.
Oh, man.
Oh.
Clearly, she means she watches my hero academia.
I do.
But not on the iPad.
Mm-hmm.
I mean my cereal.
That's actually really good.
Tasted really good.
I'm running out of cereal.
No.
Mm-hmm.
I always play music while I shower,
so I don't have to think about life.
Music isn't enough for me.
Music, I resonate with music too much
that it puts me in the, it makes me think sometimes.
So instead, I gotta dance in the shower
while playing music.
But sometimes, because my range in music is so broad,
if I play with songs on shuffle,
there's a high chance I'm gonna get hit with a sad song.
And I don't want that song.
I already had that happen twice.
And I said to myself,
I am not gonna play music, it's a shower anymore.
I had me sad, and it had me feeling like Vegeta in the rain.
That Vegeta gift in the rain.
You scared to put your electronics in your water?
Just get a little cover.
Get a water cover.
Protect your electronics.
It'll be fine.
Mm-hmm.
No!
I dropped some cereal.
Mm-hmm.
I watched anime in the shower.
I'd do them.
I even watched a movie in the shower.
Mm-hmm.
That's why you gotta make a playlist
for specific moods.
I'm too organized that
my playlists are like
emo,
rock,
Japanese openings,
and songs.
K-pop.
R&B.
My playlist is too broad.
I can't do that,
because then one day I'm gonna be listening to rock,
and I'm like,
and then I'm gonna be like,
well, I wanna listen to this specific song
that's also kind of rock-ish,
but it's not rock-ish.
It's in the Japanese playlist.
Now I gotta go to the Japanese playlist
and you'll find the song.
Just to play the song.
That's why I just leave everything on shuffle.
Mm-hmm.
Just leave it on shuffle.
Do I listen to blues rock music?
I think so.
Sometimes.
What's cereal you're eating?
My favorite kind.
Captain Crunch,
peanut butter.
I'm not pouring another bowl.
I didn't eat the other one really fast.
I don't know what you're talking about.
This is only my second bowl.
Right?
I like cinnamon toast crunch,
but...
Okay, let's see it this way.
Imagine eating something for three years straight.
The same thing.
Nothing else, nothing new.
Three years straight.
The same thing.
Over and over and over and over and over and over again.
Are you not gonna get tired of it?
Cinnamon toast crunch used to be my favorite cereal
in the past.
But it was all my mom ever bought.
So I got tired of it really fast.
Three years straight.
It was all we could afford.
All the other brands were,
or stuff were a little more expensive.
But we couldn't get anything else.
She would only buy that and Lucky Charms.
But we weren't allowed to eat the Lucky Charms.
They were hers and hers alone.
Oh, we ate Lucky Charms.
You'd get angry.
Sorry I have a lot of aunties within my class.
I would star in an ice cream bar,
a hit sparkling tea bar
or a social television bar,
too stupid to be an ice cream lover.
I would be an ice cream lover if they'd offered me ice cream.
Friends would do that,
without 보이 rice and other cereals.
Three, four, three, four.
Let's go.
How long was your longest shower?
Five hours I fell asleep. I
Fell asleep then slid down and almost drowned
It woke me up there's a great big splash to the face
I
Rice is different though
You ate rice for 22 years rice is different. I fucking love rice
I don't think I'll ever get tired of rice. You could do so many things with rice so many different combinations with rice
Rice is like the best the best thing ever
People talk down a white rice. Right rice is amazing
A little bit of salt
Me some rice fried rice work rice
All the rice
Rice and peas rice and beans rice rice rice rice rice rice rice
That's literally why I put a rice cooker on my throat
My family has a rice cooker, but I'm not allowed to use it
I'm not allowed to use the the rice cooker
It's cuz I have really bad memory my memory is really really really bad and
My my mom wasn't aware that if you leave the rice cooker closed
Insealed the rice is still good for the next day
It's still good for the next day
But she kept opening it and then leaving it open
And then complaining that there was mold on it
I
So I had a teacher to stop opening it and leaving it open but because of the whole situation medication time
My alarm went off medication time
But I had to teach her not to open it and stuff
But because of the whole situation it took me like months to teach her not to do it or touch it or whatever
When she started doing it and leaving it closed. I thought that she was cleaning it out and
I would forget about it
I would completely forget about it. So I'd leave it in there for like days
Until it was time for me to use it again
So the rice was still in the collecting mold
So yeah, I would forget about it being in there
and then I would collect mold
But it's different if the rice cooker belonged to me and only me
I'd freely be able to eat out of it save food and I have to worry about people touching it
If no one's touching it then I can I will know when something's in it and when something isn't in it
And I would solely clean it myself
It was just really annoying because she would like
She would like take a picture
Send it to me, but like hey look it's moldy
Am I okay? Right? I'm gonna clean it. Clean it
And she just keep doing that over and over
Even if someone else used it, I had to clean it. So it was annoying. It was very annoying
To constantly be annoyed by it my brain just automatically like just no longer cared about it anymore
I
Stressed out over a rice cooker
I was like I'll forget about it. I just won't eat rice won't make my own rice anymore
After a rice is good for fried white rice, it's true
I'm right so bad
You met a cereal by the way
You had fried chicken and fried rice for dinner nice. I only had fried chicken, but it wasn't for dinner
sadly
It was for lunch
My mom made it before she left
Excuse me to talk about rice. Rice is amazing. What? You don't have time to talk about rice
I
Don't realize
I think the most food traumatizing thing
That my mom did was forced me to eat mushrooms. It's one of the reasons why I don't like mushrooms
I'm a little traumatized from mushrooms
So I really don't like mushrooms
She would make us eat it we were broke II so she would force us to eat
One thing she'd would make was you know spaghetti and meatballs
Spaghetti and meatballs minus the meatball replace it with mushrooms
She'd make that all the time
All the time and I can't I can't I can't no
No
Oh
She would get so angry we wouldn't finish our food she'd make us stay up at the table
We have to sit there and she was like you can't leave you can't go to bed unless you finish this
Me and my my siblings
We were such bad children ah
We would find multiple ways to dispose of the evidence
Oh
No, we chuck it chuck it out the window we hide it we'll flush it
So bad
Oh man
Oh
We used to be such food wasters things changed after that
Things changed so much
I remember being um
We were like I experienced true starvation for the first time
We were homeless for a little bit
For a little bit we were homeless
Yeah
Yeah, like a big dead
We're homeless
I've been homeless before
So I know
I'm gonna have a big tail and
We won't eat for
For so long
And all I would eat was bread
Bread bread. I love bread. It's my savior
Uh
I felt so bad about how much food I wasted in the past
Makes you really think
I'm not out of the clear water yet
I'm barely hanging on with rent
We're barely hanging on
But hopefully you're hopefully it won't happen again
We're fine now
For now
I
Thank you appreciate that. That's very sweet of you to say about my love. Thank you
They were chopped mushrooms by the way
Is it a flavor thing or texture thing? No, it's just trauma. I think it's just trauma
Uh mental mental thing
I get really nauseous whenever I try to eat a mushroom every now and then
They're really nauseous even if I eat it and I don't know what's a mushroom. It's like
It's like a taste you can't really forget
So I think it's just a mental thing
Same goes for raisins. I used to really like raisins a lot growing up
but again trauma
My grandma my grandma's house when I stayed with her she had a mice and stuff and
bugs infestation and
Wasn't like extremely bad, but
Her food was not safe
um
I think flies got into the
raisins
And I was eating them
Eating the box of raisins. It's just enjoying them. Hmm raisins. Yum. Yum. Yum. So good. Hmm
And then I poured out the last little bit into my hand
And there were about four maggots in my hand
And
Swiggling about in my hand
And ever since then I never ate raisins
You let an interesting life, I guess I suppose so
I've been through quite a lot
I
Have like so many stories I can tell you guys I have I have
I've been through quite a bit and they're very memorable
I remember stuff when I was five
I was five years old. I remember stuff way back then a lot of memories
I remember it's pretty good when it comes to remembering the really really good and the really really bad
But it's not good for much anything else
It has to have a stain on my brain for me to remember
I
Give me the elevator perch for your weirdest stories mention them speaking of elevators
Speaking of elevators, I have a bunch of elevator story for you
I
Didn't get stuck in an elevator that's old news. Come on. Everybody has had had gone. They had been stuck. Wow
Wow
English English is great
Everyone's gone stuck in an elevator at least once at least once
I got stuck in an elevator twice
twice
I was really really really young when the first time it happened
And there was a blackout and the elevator stopped working the blackout in the building and the elevator stopped working
So it was dark in the elevator. I remember being in an elevator with other people
I didn't really know what was happening. I was confused. So I was like, what's happening? Why is it so dark? And then
I was in an elevator with like a
family member and they were screaming at the top foot there
And that is what scared me. I'm actually really terrified of the dark and terrified of elevators
All right, let me put on details more details. It's not just elevators. I'm afraid of I'm afraid of man-made machinery
Man-made machinery that can and will mount function as what I'm afraid of I have a fear of machines
But I have no other choice but to use them. So I tough through it
I tough through it. I'm also claustrophobic. So yeah
Yes, I'm scared of escalators as well
I get shaky knees when I'm on them, but I have no other choice. I'm also afraid of planes
I'm afraid of planes
I'm not
super afraid of cars
But I I do
Get really really sick. I don't know if it's motion sickness, but I doubt it because I've been on a boat
I don't think it's motion sickness. I think I just get car sick the smell of the car
Being in it feeling closed off
I uh
Oh, I'm sorry give me a second
Wow
Even thinking about it makes me freak out
a little
Panic attack and then I uh, I get really nauseous and I really massive headache
Massive really big
So the only way I could ride in a car is if I uh
If I have a window open
I
But I tough through it usually I don't say anything
I sit in the car really quietly and I like lean my head against the door and I don't say anything
I don't want no one to worry or freak out and stuff the last time I brought it up to
It was like I was in a cab and the person in the cab freaked out because I was like panicking
I was like, please please can you open a window and they were like, it's cold. I was like, please please
Please please please please and they were like
And then I freaked out and then I freaked out and then we were freaking out
So I just don't say anything
I know what I don't want I don't want I don't want to freak out my hands are shaking. Oh my gosh
And I think I've been in a near accident in a car before
I've been in an accident twice, but the other one wasn't that bad, but I think it was like
Uh, one of my family members kind of scared me
They were like, oh, we got to be careful. We got to be careful
We're all gonna be doomed and oh it's gonna be over and then she started doing a prayer and I was like, oh my god
I'm going to die
Oh
But yeah, I've been stuck at elevator a couple of times, but I think the funny elevator stories I have for you
Don't have to really deal with these
It's just
Sorry
It's not my story, but let me tell you
About my mom
I'm tearing up already
So, you know, I I live in a in a place where you know bugs are a big problem
And you know what kind of like bug is a really big problem
You know, because they're kind of really big
And gross
And a creepy crawly, you know, they're big and gross
We call them
Waterbugs, but I know what a real water bug looks like. It's not really a water bug. It's just a giant
Cockroach
This is a really big one
And you know
You know, they're really not nice to be around. They're scary. They're big. They're massive
No, it's like it's a cockroach cockroach
Those those are not nice. Those are gross. They're gross and they're massive
Well, my mom got into an elevator with a kind gentleman
She got into the elevator with a kind gentleman and they were added up in the elevator
And bam, there it was
It was crawling about and my mom she really just
She does not like insects. She does not like them at all not one bit
And did you do you know a fun fact about cockroaches you want to know a fun fact
You
The cockroaches have this thing they can do
Cockroaches have this really cool thing they can do
Which is fly
They can fly
So this cockroach starts flying and it's flying everywhere and then she's stuck in this elevator with this kind gentleman
And she sits flying and she's screaming and she's screaming
And she starts clinging to this poor man
She's holding him for dear life. She's clinging to him like a Scooby-Doo
Oh
Oh god
And you know what makes it better, you know what makes why I laugh so hard you want to know why I laugh so hard
It's because I could hear everything I can hear I hear screaming
Ah
That's a lot she was screaming she was screaming so loud I can't hear everything she's in the elevator
And she came out she said she was so embarrassed
She was so embarrassed
She said the guy didn't even react he didn't move he didn't even do anything. He just stood there
She screamed at yourself hiding in it. Oh my god
She said he didn't even react. He just stood there
Oh
Oh, it was the greatest. Oh, oh, it was amazing
And you know
You know, it's great. This is the first time this happened
This also happened to another sibling of mine
How it happened to my my sister
She also got stuck in the elevator, but she was by herself this time
And I also heard her too
Ah
It was great
Uh
Wow
I can't say that I haven't gone through
I I haven't gone through what they went through being stuck in the elevator with one, but I've had a similar
situation
A similar situation
When I still had my my cat
Uh
His name was kuro
Uh, when I saw my cat kuro
My throat holy water
Water break
I'm still laughing too much
When I saw my cat
He liked to hunt down bugs and stuff
But one day I decided to take a bath
I decided to take a bath a nice
Relaxing bath
I showered beforehand get the little muck off me first so I don't bathe in my own
muck
And
I I turned on the water I had candles lit for myself
Oh
It was the best and I was like
I didn't even have a phone with me at some I don't think I I didn't have anything with me in there
I was relaxing. It was so good
And I laid there in the bath relaxing with the door cracked door was cracked
Because my cat hates when I closed the door. He hated it. He did not like when I closed the door
He would sit at the door scratching at it. Meow
Meow
Meow open the door
Close the door
Open the door
Meow
He hated it so I had a door cracked
And he started shuffling about doing I thought he had the zoomies or something and he was like running back for it
And and then he comes through the cat
I got a door and just
Barges in and then he's like at the corner of the tub and the wall
like
And I'm like, what are you doing silly? What are you doing?
What are you doing?
You're a silly cat. You're so silly
Is something there? What are you doing? Is it just is it a small bug?
I'll kill it. I'll get the small bug
Moves the like stuff out of the way
And it's a massive cockroach massive huge and I
I I just started screaming screaming
I
I run out I run out of the tub boy niggi boy niggi and run out where I run
It's funny
My mom my mom comes out yells at me. Why am I screaming? Why are you screaming?
She's angry at me for screaming later at night. Why are you screaming? Why are you screaming?
And I'm like get it get it get it
She looks down and she's like
Oh
Yeah
We had a
Cockroaches incident in a while. It's been a couple of years now. This was so long ago
It's a while now
They clean it up now
We haven't had an incident in a while
This is good
I don't mind the small ones the small ones are fine like I'm I'm murder those
Die die evens die
But the big ones
Because then what are you going to do like how are you going how you going to murder it?
We shoot like
Oh, like it's going to go crunch
Squelch and pop like
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
I
Hate mosquitoes hate them with a burning passion. I suffer to them every day
But because of this fan, I haven't had a mosquito problem in a minute. Thanks
They they they they are annoying. I hate when they buzz in your ear
He
Hate mosquitoes
I like
Some spiders, but I'm actually really scared of spiders, but I think some of them are really cute
I think jumping spiders and tarantulas are the cutest things that they're so fuzzy so dangerous
But so fuzzy and cute
Look at that. So cute. I like jumping spiders. I think the big beady eyes are as little
Big eyes
They're really cute
But I am still scared of
Spiders I leave the house spiders alone. I used to have a spider friend in the corner of my room
But I haven't seen it in a while
Um, it usually like disappears for a few days and then comes back in the same corner
But it's been gone for like two weeks now
Probably moved on to new endeavors
But I had spider scares where a spider would appear in my showers
Like uh fall down. I've had a spear fear of spiders for a while
And
Yeah, I usually take them out of the house too and put them out in the window
Yeah, go away little spider
Goodbye
But I don't do it. I get someone else to do it because I'm not gonna do it. I'm not going nowhere near one
Same goes for fireflies. I'm just really I just don't I'm not a big bug person
I'm not a big bug person
Like I like fireflies they look so pretty and I'm sure they're very they're harmless, but they're terrifying
They move around so much
I think spiders are fine though. I really like snakes and all those stuff
But the fire is okay some of them
If they look scary, I don't like them
But if they look big like they're cute and fuzzy and stuff, then that's fine. I like those the big fuzzy big fuzzy ones
I think those are cute
You
Would not believe your eyes is 10 million fireflies lit up the world
Stare
I
Fireflies big some depends there's multiple different types of fireflies and the ones over here pretty pretty fucking big
But I think they're like going extinct over here
Haven't really had many for the last couple of years
Yeah, they kind of like show up and then
Be no more
There's less and less every year
I make my stomach hurt
Oh
Road-sized fireflies. Oh my stomach
No, please no, no
We had a nice chat today. It was a nice chatting
You guys are pretty chill
Yeah, yeah, there's a little behaved but you're good boys and girls in here
Ah
My throat is starting to hurt. I don't remember if I took my medication if I'm honest
I mentioned my alarm and then I mentioned my medication, but I do not remember if I took it
I
Can't take the
I can't take the heart medication because I did drink
And I'm uh, I don't want to take chances. So we're not going to take that for today. It's okay to miss a day
It's perfectly fine. I miss a day, but the
Pankillers I need it would make if I didn't take my
If I didn't take the painkillers, it would make sense why I have a massive like
The robbing like headache on a side
I
Feel like I did
That's a myth
I remember taking something
I think I did
I think I did I did I did I 100% did I did
I
Did not take my inhaler though that I did not take that's for sure
I think I did take it immediately. I have my memory is just so bad
And I don't need to take my nasal spray today. I took it earlier in the day because I was having those problems earlier
That's it, you know, I think I'm good. I think it's fine. Yeah
Yeah
Hey reminds me
I yeah, I usually have like a bunch of alarms, but
I was so sleepy that I'm like
Not sure
Yeah
I'm not sure
Well, since I'm sleepy, I think we're gonna call you here for the rest of the night
No, I didn't enjoy playing with you guys
Have a fun
But the the eep necessary to hit be really really hard
So we're gonna call it for tonight. Who's live right now? Mercy, right?
Marseille's live
Mercy and she be she was live. What the hell how long has she been live for?
She be is live? I must go see
Like all of the lamb
I
Some hours holy shit
She sounds drunk she sounds so sleepy
She sounds so sleepy
Sounds so sleepy
I want to play call to the lamb so bad I've cut the lamb
How long do you think she'll be streaming for you think she's gonna end soon
I
See go come back here
You
Mercy did just start yeah
Yeah, we'll be a mercy
Wow
Good night, everyone. Good night. Good night. Good night
You're like you're also eager
He's very strong. You're welcome. You know, I love my kicks really good rest
Hi everyone, and um, so if you guys haven't already done so like and subscribe
Like and subscribe and ring that bell for a notification
Uh, so we have merch
So be sure to click the link down below in the description to get your merch today
Have me close to your heart. Don't you want to wear me?
Yeah
Hey
Night night everyone night night. Bye. Have you made it this far?
And tell me that
I'm awesome
I want
I